in the last video we began our
exploration of what a consumption
function is that's a fairly
straightforward idea it's a function
that describes how aggregate income can
drive aggregate consumption and we start
with a fairly simple model of this a
fairly simple consumption function it
was a linear one you had some base level
of consumption regardless of aggregate
income and then you had some level of
consumption that was essentially induced
by having some disposable income and
when we plotted this linear model we got
a line we got a line right over here and
i pointed out in the last video this
does not have to be the only way that a
consumption function can be described
you might use some fancier mathematical
tools maybe you can construct a
consumption function you have an
argument you'd argue that the marginal
propensity to consume is is higher at
lower levels of disposable income and
then it it kind of tapers out as
disposable income as aggregate
disposable income goes up and so you
might think that maybe you should have a
fancier consumption function that when
you graph it would look like this and
then you would have to use things
fancier than just what we used right
over here what i want to do in this
video is focus more on a linear model
and the reason why i'm going to focus on
a linear model is because one it's
simpler it'll be easier to manipulate
and it's also the model that tends to be
used right when people are starting to
digest things like consumption functions
and building on them to learn about
things like and we'll do this in a few
videos the keynesian cross but what i'm
going to do is i'm going to do two
things i'm going to generalize this
linear consumption function and i'm
going to make it a function not just of
disposable income but
not just of aggregate disposable income
which is what we did in the last video
but as a function of income of aggregate
income and then we will plot that
generalized one based on the variables
but it's really going to be the same
thing we're just not going to use these
numbers we're going to use variables in
their place
so let's give ourselves a linear
consumption function
so we could say that aggregate
consumption aggregate consumption where
we're going to have some base level of
consumption no matter what even if
people have no aggregate income they
need to survive they need food on the
table and maybe they'll have to dig in
savings somehow to do it so some base
level of consumption i'll call that
lowercase c
sub zero or lowercase c with a subscript
of zero right over there that's the base
level of aggregate consumption or
sometimes referred to as autonomous
consumption
this is autonomous
autonomous
consumption
because people will do it on their own
or in aggregate they will do it on their
own even if they have no aggregate
income
and then we will have the part that is
due directly due to having some
aggregate income and we call that the
induced consumption because you could
view it as being induced by having some
aggregate income so above and beyond
what the base level of consumption
people are going to consume some
fraction of their disposable income so
we'll say disposable
disposable
income and they're not going to consume
all of their disposable income they
might save some of it so they're going
to consume the fraction that's
essentially their marginal propensity to
consume so this right over here i'll do
that in i'll do that in this orange
color marginal propensity to consume so
that is
marginal propensity to consume and
hopefully this makes intuitive sense
this says look if this was a hundred
people are going to consume 100 no
matter what 100 billion whatever your
unit of currency is now their marginal
propensity to consume is let's say it is
a third and you have now above and
beyond this people have disposable
income of let's say 900 this is saying
that they're going to they want to
consume a third of that of that
disposable income they're getting that
is if you give them 900 of extra
disposal income their propensity to
consume that marginal in that that
incremental income they're going to
consume a third of it and so this would
be a third so it would be 900 so let me
give an example so if you had a
situation so you could have a situation
where c naught is equal to what did i
say did i say it was like 100
and if you have disposable income
disposable income
is equal to 900
and c1 is equal to one-third or we could
say 0.333 repeating forever c1 is a
third then this makes sense on their own
people would consume this much but now
they have this disposable income their
marginal propensity to consume if you
give them 900 extra of income they're
going to consume a third of that so then
you're going to have your consumption is
going to be equal to for this case right
over here your consumption is going to
be 100 times or plus one-third plus
one-third times 900
times 900 and so your consumption in
this situation your induced consumption
one-third times 900 would be 300 and
maybe it's in billions of dollars 300
billion dollars and then your autonomous
consumption would be 100 and they would
add up to they would add up to 400. so
once again this is autonomous and this
is induced autonomous
this right over here is induced
induced consumption
consumption
now i did write it in general terms i'm
using variables here instead of instead
of or constants really instead of using
instead of using the numbers that we saw
in the last example
but i also said that i would express
aggregate consumption as a function not
just of disposable income but of
aggregate income not just of aggregate
disposable income but aggregate income
and the relationship is fairly simple
between disposable income and overall
income we saw over here
in aggregate you have income but the
government in most modern economies
takes some fraction of that out for
taxes and what's left over is disposable
income and so and just a reminder income
in aggregate aggregate income is the
same thing as aggregate expenditures
which is the same thing as aggregate
output this right over here is gdp
so this right over here is let me do
this in a color i've used almost all my
colors this is equal to gdp so
disposable income is essentially
gdp or you could say aggregate income
minus taxes
minus
minus i want to do the taxes in a
different color
minus
taxes
minus taxes so we can express disposable
income
as aggregate income
this right over here is the same thing
as aggregate income minus taxes
minus taxes so we can rewrite our whole
thing over again
aggregate consumption is equal to
autonomous consumption plus the marginal
propensity to consume
times
aggregate income which is the same thing
as gdp
times aggregate income
minus taxes
minus taxes and so we fully generalized
our consumption function and now we've
written it as a function of aggregate
income not just aggregate disposable
income and to make you comfortable that
this is still a line if we write it if
we were to plot it as a function of
aggregate income instead of disposable
income let me manipulate this thing a
little bit so we can distribute c1 which
is our marginal propensity to consume
and we get
aggregate consumption is equal to
autonomous consumption and then we're
going to distribute this plus c so we're
going to multiply it times both of these
terms plus our marginal propensity to
consume times aggregate income times
aggregate income and then minus
our marginal propensity to consume
times our taxes
and since we're going to where we want
it as a function of aggregate income
everything else here is really a
constant we're assuming that those
aren't going to change those are
constant variables and so what we can do
is we can rewrite this in a form that
you're probably familiar with back in
algebra class you probably remember line
you can write it in the form y is equal
to
mx plus b
where if where x is the independent
variable y is the dependent variable if
you were to plot this
on the horizontal axis is your x-axis
your
x-axis vertical axis is your y-axis that
this right over here would have a
y-intercept or your vertical axis
intercept of b right over there and then
it would be a line with slope m so if
you were to take your rise divided by
your run or how much you move up when
you move to the right a certain amount
that gives you that gives you your m
slope is equal to m so the same analogy
is here we can rewrite this in that form
where our dependent variable is no
longer y our dependent variable is
aggregate consumption and our
independent variable is not x it is
aggregate income so let's write it in
that form so we can write it as
dependent variable c which we'll plot on
the vertical axis is equal to
it's going to be equal to the marginal
propensity to consume times aggregate
income
times aggregate income let's see i was
doing that purple color times aggregate
income plus autonomous consumption
plus autonomous consumption minus
marginal propensity to consume times
taxes
so minus
marginal propensity to consume times
taxes now it looks all complicated but
you just have to realize
that this part right over here this is
all constant this is all constant and it
is analogous to the b
it's analogous to the b if you were to
write things in kind of traditional
slope intercept form right over here so
when we plot the line if you have no if
you have no aggregate income this is
what your consumption is going to be so
let me draw that
so once again our independent our
dependent variable i should say is
aggregate consumption and our
independent variable in this is no
longer disposable income like we did in
the last video it is now aggregate
income
it is now aggregate income it is
aggregate income so there's no aggregate
income this is the independent variable
right over here if there's no aggregate
income then your consumption is just
going to be this value right over here
so your consumption is just going to be
that value right over there which is
c naught minus c 1
times t
and then as as you have larger as you
have larger values of aggregate income
c1 that fraction of it is what's going
to contribute to the induced consumption
and so what you essentially have is this
is the slope of our line this right over
here is our slope just to kind of draw
the analogy if you would say you know y
is equal to mx plus b or actually maybe
i'll write it like this
if you were to write c
c is equal to
m
and i don't want to confuse you if this
m and b seem like completely four and
this is where it comes from kind of a
traditional algebra grounding in slope
and y-intercept so if we were to say
is c is equal to
m y
plus b
plus b this is the slope this is our
vertical or our our our dependent
variable intercept right over here
that's where we intercept the dependent
variable axis and this is our slope it's
our marginal propensity to consume so
our line will look something like this
where the slope
slope is equal to the marginal
propensity to consume which is equal to
c1 if people all of a sudden are more
likely to spend a larger fraction of
their income then the marginal
propensity of consume the marginal
propensity to consume would be higher
and our slope would be higher we would
have a line that looks like that and we
always assume that the marginal
propensity to consume will be less than
one so we'll never have a slope of one
but we'll also never have a negative
slope because we assume that this is
positive and if people are more likely
to save then consume when they have
extra income then this line might look
something like that might have a lower
slope